um six months ago that the UK was one of
the big talking topics here in
Washington after the mini budget and
what was happening in the guilts market
I just wanted you know six months on
whether what's happened since is you
know cautionary tale or have things
actually is is it an exemplary case in
what to do when you're faced with a
crisis like that how is the UK doing
right now uh it's certainly the case
that there was forceful action by the
bank of England and I was able to uh to
calm the markets very quickly I mean
it's one of the episodes we've had of
this uh uh rapid increase in in interest
rates uh creating some pockets of
vulnerabilities in the in the financial
sector in that case in uh vehicles that
were associated with uh with the UK
pensions
um so certainly as we've seen also in
the US uh forceful action from financial
and monetary authorities was was very
decisive decisive here